[Music]
ain't no competition in the ring of
cipher cause i'm spitting
swinging fire talking pickled peppers
make them pay the piper cause i might go
look like a rude discussion and deflate
your chest like a food production you be
talking like you want a new concussion
center due to custom attitude
adjustments
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
sound
michael jackson even got his one and
only homie captain you a phony homie now
you owe me action have him sinking tony
tony tony braxton and they all want to
talk for attention but the fame only
lasts for an instant momma got hands so
i'm ready for the tension i'ma leave him
ready
[Music]
what's going on people
what's going on
welcome to another episode of combat
talk with the king
hope everybody got the
drink situations ready for this uh
charlo castano too
this this
this is gonna be some stuff today boy
um i'm i'm predicting maybe fight of the
year be honest with you
uh
so
today
it's pina colada
oh it's mixing
let me see who that
what's good another good fight that's
right sam
sean that's what's up
let me let me let me let me zoom this up
man
i don't got sovereign out here
reading my super chats being extra great
so
i gotta do this myself
what was that about right there that
looked kind of weird on the screen
oh
yo i think attic still got
whatchamacallit
what the hell just happened
oh my god yo i got a little green thing
there that i gotta get off of it
let me let's see
fix that right there
yeah
that will be busy as hell boy
they'd be busy as hell
let me see if i can get that a little
bit clearer for y'all
you can't
let me see
yo i think that green screen yo at it i
think that green screen thing
is still on in the background and i got
to get that thing off of there
because you know we was doing this green
screen thing
and
i got to get that off of it i don't know
what the hell is going on
let me see
was it in this right here
we got uh jerome boots and it's this uh
that fight today i cannot wait to see
that fight
addict
i know you're watching
text me right now how to pop that green
screen thing off cause for some weird
reason our hats
is right there you see the show right
there i don't know it's just weird it's
just
something's popping up on the screen and
it should not be there like there's
nothing on the camera see
but it's right there
come here like a little straw or
something
oh that's my straw
yeah
it was picking up my yo anybody is
watching this don't mess with me
all right so bus out bust it right
me and addict was supposed to be doing
the green screen because i have some
stuff set up later so i got a whole
green screen that's in the back now i
usually don't have the green straw
usually the green straw is for my wife
and i have the red straw so i'm like
what the hell is that on the screen what
the hell is that it must be the
the the green screen because we was we
was trying some stuff out man addict
yo
my wife took my drink
i took her drink right
and her drink
has the green straw so now
i got to move it off the screen
but that that was what it was oh my god
i'm sitting there like what the hell is
going on
yeah
yeah don't even and and if you start
clowning me
ban you
yeah what's going on what's going on
all right who's up in here
we got 14 in here that's what's up
what's going on guys
hit that like button that's right
thanks attic yeah so listen attic helped
me in the beginning with the uh the
sound from the the sound issues from
last week
and i went out and i got a light source
because i thought i was looking a little
bit too dark
uh so
yo so we got jerome jeron boots in us
right he is the future of the walter
weight division he is coming up next and
he's fighting this dude
that um
the guy is pretty decent
um
[Music]
i think he's gonna give him a good test
because it's it's the step up in his
progression but after this they're
talking about he fighting keith thurman
if if geron
fights keith thurman
that's that's a hell of a pay-per-view
if this boy next fight is a pay-per-view
then he's a star in the makings
yeah i know my stroll look crazy uh
don't don't don't clown me i'm gonna
have to get my wife to bring down my
stroll but i don't have um
working with graphic guard doing this
other stuff
so
i'm gonna have like time-out screens
i want a time-out screen where people
were really fighting
so that's what i want so
what's going on what's going on son
everybody's here it would be a fire
crack of a fight yo it's definitely
going to be a fire crack of a fight yo
who said is a ghost is it cozy are you
so stupid
better not be in here because this show
will be telling itself
yo you see my grow girl right there he
looks so cute right
shout out to my little grow girl
still stuff oh my god so right now
they they're giving you
uh jerome boots and his story
and right now he's warming up in the
back um he's fighting clayton
and you know that's the next bout
that's a good fight i mean that's a
really good fight this card is a really
good card it's uh you know a lot of
times the pbc puts together really good
cards with really good fighters
because they have a lot of the wall to
weight division
what's going on
yeah to be on the next paypal
yo
tell me
are y'all listening to all the stuff in
the background as far as this bud
crawford
versus um spence
and the fact that uh the pay-per-view
numbers came in
and and and spence is commanding a huge
large piece of that pie
i don't know i think but gonna have to
take a shot to in order to to get the
fight i mean you come into the fight
with one belt right
so
you're going up some against a champion
who has three belts and has been a
pay-per-view sensation i think he should
you know take a little you know of a
step back it should be a 70 30 split
three belts equals you know that that's
70 pi
and that 30 split equals you know his
his his portion right
oh thank you thank you yeah attic attic
worked with me on getting my mic fixed
so um i do apologize first two like it's
growing pains you're gonna we're gonna
have a whole
overlay
everything um so if y'all have any
suggestions you know you follow me on
twitter go on twitter
hit me up on twitter hit me in the
background let me know your king you
should do this or you know this stuff
should happen or whatever and i'm
definitely going to try to implement
those things um
try to have other stuff for you know you
guys to talk about it and see an
interactive what we are going to do
we are working on call-ins
so you guys are going to be able to call
in and have a whole conversation so
right now the drink of the evening is
pina colada
i made them myself
so i use in pina coladas you know you
use the ice
and um
pineapple juice uh coke cream of the
cocoa
um
and
the the the liquid that i use
is malleable
and the only reason why i go with the
malibu rum is because it's not a dark
room it's a light rum and it fits more
with the feeling and the taste of a pina
colada opposed to
like a harder uh rum it's a nice smooth
rum and nothing crazy you know
who's the favorite in this fight with
boost innis or who's the favorite for
the eman charlo is a slight favorite
going up against castano i don't know
why he's a slight favorite going up
against castano to be honest with you i
would call it the even bet i thought the
last fight it was deserved to be a draw
i i thought charlo
hurt castano
more than castano hurt charlo
excuse me but i thought castano
did more work
that argentinian brother he was putting
in
more pressure more work and that's the
first time we saw
charlo working off the bat foot back
foot and the fact that he's able to work
off the back foot shows you that he's a
good boxer so that means he can fight
going forward he can fight going lateral
but he also can fight going back and up
and he learned in that fight that uh
cassania didn't come here to lay down so
he was uh really
relying on
pot shouting and catching and pitching
and so so like when he was catching on
his arm he'll flip off his arm to give a
good counter it was really good so
that's why he caught cassandra with a
couple of punches and castano learned
what he was trying to do and tried not
to attack in the same manner he varied
his attack throughout the whole fight
all right sounds great thank you addict
let me see definitely sounds great this
week
who's the favorite fight told you that
any favorite tequilas yeah um
let me see we just got this new one and
that tequila was really good
i forgot i posted it the other day it
comes in a really tall bottle uh it's
it's it's monolithic it's um it's a
really good tequila
and
what's the other one that she really
likes um
uh it comes in that little bottle she
has to text me uh but the new one the
new one i'm gonna get it and i'm gonna
post it on twitter excuse me
that one is definitely the the best
tequila that i've tasted so far because
it's not harsh and it's like it's smooth
so
yes that's good espanol yeah
yeah it's really place yo no it's not in
the blue bottle it's in a black bottle
uh
jeez
and i got it upstairs i should tell my
wife to bring it downstairs
oh uh leonta tequila lienta
and the anti-ticket is she texting me
because she's watching it she she's
watching me right now
um yeah they have different levels of it
so we got the the middle level they have
another level i think it's 150 dollars
so we got the 100 bottle and it's a 150
bottle that's like the next bottle after
that that dead bottle we're gonna try
that one i don't know maybe memorial
weekend never know you never know
i know next week
tank is fighting next week
and i do apologize next week
we won't have combat talk because
the boy needs a vacation the boy needs a
vacation boy needs to be doing something
so
stuff needs to happen king have you had
any donkey rum yeah don q is dope
donkey
is really good with whatever you want to
mix it with right so you have to let me
get this little green thing out of the
way because it'd be tripping me out
um you got to know what you're going to
mix it with they're showing ll cool jlo
cool j's at the fight
um
but for my pina colada i gotta go with
the malibu it's it's not too harsh it's
just right has a nice mix it's a little
bit sweet so and and even if you just do
it with just pina
just like that it's fine you understand
so
it it all depends on what taste that
you're looking for but you know it's
fight night so fight night you got a
little drink and you know you watch the
fight with your loved ones
usually it's some chips
she posted uh she uh
if y'all can see that right there that's
the bottle it's a tall bottle
let me move it back or whatever
yeah yeah that's the bottle of it right
there
so
yeah
that's it it's it's a it's a it's a
really good nice drink it's nothing
nothing crazy
so like you know how sometimes you're
doing shots with tequila
and you just like wow you like all of a
sudden it hits you nah that one is it's
kind of smooth so right now we got
jerome in his
versus uh custo clayton
now i'm not gonna lie uh jerome
is the
betting fan
better favorite in this fight
uh but
clayton
has a little bit of a pedigree
and
he he definitely can give him a run for
his money
in this fight but because they have a
mutual uh fight that they had with lip
and yet
so lip and yet is a
veteran
and drone knocked them out no one ever
knocked out lip and yet right so clayton
fought lipid yet and he went to a draw
with him
jeron fought lip and yet
and knocked him out and that fight
i never seen jerome look better
than that than that fight so
we got something to see so they're in
the ring right now
juron is in the ring um
and so is clayton
he's wearing a pink
fluffy collar jerome is and pink and
white
and you know um
breast awareness uh you know a lot of
guys wear that for you know breast
awareness support
we have to support our women
you know
especially you know and cancer awareness
in general you know we have to support
you know everyone that uh
suffers with this affliction you know
until we can find a way to
eradicate it off this planet we got to
show some support in some form of
fashion
oh man thank you so much yo i'm living
great right now because all you guys is
here
we got uh 20 people watching we got 19
likes that that's that's what's up man
i'm gonna tell you right now
if you don't got nobody to hang out with
on saturday
i'm here to hang out with you
and we can talk these fights
so all right so jeron is a couple of
inches taller he's five ten
uh uh clayton is five eight
they both weighed the same coming into
this fight um on reach will be in
jerome's favor drawn favor
um
this fight is is is telling because i
wanted to see this fight more than
a lot of undercard fights right this in
the next fight is the main event
right so we're we're at the precipice of
the next fight if uh jerome knocks this
guy out early uh-uh we're gonna be
getting an early fight
hit that like button this was good
he said i got you saturday but who got
you the rest of the week
he's stupid
any tips on getting into boxing how old
are you
boxing for recreation boxing for
money
boxing for
getting into shape boxing for
just you know learning how to fight it's
all it's a lot of different things um
any tips okay i'm of casual follower
usually fights at parties yeah that's
right um
so if you're just talking about getting
into boxing
the genre itself and not the physical
sport all right 28 so we definitely know
you're not talking about fighting for a
living and we talking about just
following the sport all i say is
with anything
like with video games with comic books
with anything
you go you see something that you like
excuse me
and then
you stick to it you follow up on it so
if you see somebody fighting tonight and
you say oh man i like how i do fights or
whatever go back check his old fights
see his old fights uh see his fight
schedule see who's gonna fight next
then you start fighting that pers or
following that person male or female
because there's a lot of female fighters
that i love to watch like caresses
shields
you start watching or taylor and stuff
if you start watching these fighters and
you start following them then you're
gonna see other fighters and then you're
gonna see other stuff that you like and
then you're just gonna branch off and
you're gonna go from one fighter to the
next and you're gonna go from one
organization to the next i'm talking
about when i'm talking to organizations
i'm talking about like pbc
um
uh oscar de la hoya's group uh the zone
and that stuff
great memera's fight yeah with the
knockout yeah definitely
so they just announced both of them
and they're trying to drag it out
because i guess they weren't supposed to
get to this part of the night
and
right now it's still light outside i
think they're fighting in california
excuse me
it's still light outside
yeah jerome is giron is very tall
compared to clayton
he towers over him
all right so
they're getting ready uh ring the bell
and they're at uh their respective
corners
this is gonna be a lit show
i really think that um
jaron probably fills him out for two to
three rounds and then goes in for the
kill because he's he's a a stalker boxer
puncher
all right so
here we go jerome starts with a light
jab just a feel out and he uh tried to
give him a leap and left hook he's
varying the jab drone is top to bottom
clayton's in a defensive posture
uh he's putting his hands up in the
middle of the ring
jerome is jabbing forward while he's
stepping so
what they're doing right now is just
filling each other out jerome every time
he steps in he moves with a jab
fundamentals um deep boxing
and he's he's has the right hand set to
toss but he's not throwing it at all so
it's it's a jab straight in
again
and he's uh loosening up his arms
again clayton is is there in a defensive
positive not throwing anything jeron is
just um
just tapping just trying to find a
weakness
shout out to that super chat from
hollywood rules king thanks for this bro
who did this for you
facts man listen
i needed to hang out with everybody else
too i know you dudes definitely need uh
something to do on the weekends and i
definitely need to be hanging out with
people and and giving back my love
and i love this sport so again they're
doing the same thing jerome trying to
find a weakness clayton just trying to
survive for a little bit later rounds in
order to to to
get to jerome but jerome just did a
looping
right hand
if he doesn't push geron
it can only end one way
right if you keep chipping at a wall he
did a one-two drum there to one two
and the two did get in but it lands
slightly off the side of
clayton's head
now the one two is a left hand right
hand combination now jerome uh switched
to southpaw
all right so he's able he's ambidextrous
he can go right-handed or he can go uh
left-handed
and right now he switched to southpaw so
he's throwing a right-handed jab
at uh clayton
and he's picking at clayton's uh defense
but nothing's getting through
i wouldn't have never
you know told um
geron to switch to southpaw yet
all right so it's a stiff uh jab he
tried to throw up a cut with the left
but he didn't land
he's he's he's
he's a very good boxer to follow
and to hit your wagon too because he's
very young and he has a high skill
all right so right now he's just jabbing
again
very low output round for clayton
and he tried to hit on the break right
now with jaron
but nothing tyrone punched him in the
stomach ended a round
i give the round to jerome because of
just the pure activity of it you know
clayton really wasn't doing anything 21
watching 24 likes that's what's up
what's good people
max what's good you back baby
that's what i'm talking about so um
ennis is standing up in the corner
he didn't even really do anything to
even sit down a lot of times you don't
want to sit down because you don't want
to cramp your legs
that's not something that you want to do
you want to make sure
that your legs is uncramped
right clayton is sitting down and he's
looking like a deer in the headlights
big cloud what's going on remember 15
months my brother you watching the usc
fight tonight nope
i'm watching the boxing event i watch
the ufc fight later on with my wife
uh um
as i go over that and start learning
that but right now now we have one of
the the best
walter wait um
super welterweight matches
that we had probably in uh 10 years we
just had the first one and this is for
all the belts the unified champion
this is crazy undisputed this is nuts
who hit me
yes but i don't want those burgers right
now baby
oh
impossible burgers
sp 10 super chat we're in for some good
fights tonight yes we are this is
definitely 100 the truth
all right so they're back in the center
of the ring all right so clayton
actually tried to throw some punches uh
jaron is still in the southpaw stance so
he's throwing
looping right hands around
uh clayton's uh guard jabbing in the
center of the ring they're all in the
center of the ring i don't know why
jerome doesn't just stalk him down uh
because he's hitting them to the body
and he's going to the right hand
all right so right now the end of break
and clayton is trying to roughhouse him
by putting his arm in his neck uh jerome
circles back out to the center of the
ring
after the ref called a break and jerome
is jabbing clayton's gloves
all right
and he's a it's a stiff jab
but is trying to he's trying to get the
jab into his guard to break his guard
all right all right so he he throws the
the right hand the right jab into his
guard and throws the left into clayton's
stomach
all this time clayton really isn't doing
too much clayton tried to attack
jerome's body with a right hand but to
no avail jeron is backing up against the
ropes now
while clayton is probably kind of trying
to stalk him but uh drawn is just
baiting him in
as he's trying to land uh the uppercut
left
to uh clayton's face
clayton is stalking him now throwing the
jab jerome is
just uh jabbing and circling into the
middle of the ring
again nothing really truly
spectacular because
clayton isn't pushing the envelope he
needs to push the envelope a little bit
further
circle in the ring
all right he hit him with a right hand
and dropped him
he knocked him out
he knocked him out he knocked him out
with a smooth right hand
that was crazy
he
listen he is knocked out
he's stumbling around the ring he
doesn't want no more of the fight
he got dropped with a right hand
and it was very very crazy
wow
great right hand i gotta look at it
again
very quick we on to the main event to be
honest with you
let me see
yeah that was a crazy knockdown
and even crazy and knockout the fact
that he didn't get i yo
ah
all right so you ever see when somebody
takes a shot and they just realize i
don't know if i really won't be here
tonight
that's what it looked like to me it
looked like i don't know if i really
want to be here tonight
so i got to see him fight somebody that
is there to win i don't think clayton
was there to win
i thought clayton was there for the step
up and give him that step up fight
and
that's that's that's not the case that's
not what we've seen here right now we
just saw jerome um and i told you for
the first two or three rounds i thought
it was gonna be a fail out for jeron he
was gonna walk him a little bit
i thought clayton would give more of
himself more energy into the fight he
didn't uh look you see clayton look
they're laughing you know they're giving
a pound good fight great one yeah yeah
yeah yeah whatever
he realized very early on the skill
level was this high he didn't want to
take a beating for the whole night
i don't i don't subscribe to that i
subscribe to
you get in there
you give it your all and they got to
drag you out
and honestly
i didn't see that all right so
if you want me to call bs on it i'm i'm
i'm calling bs on it but again
i thought the outcome would be jerome
winning anyway by knockout it came a
whole lot earlier than ice than i think
and i don't think the shot was
um as devastating as clayton made it
seem to be
to be honest with you
thank you
thank
you i don't know man you know a lot of
times
see here we go
so he shoots he shoots the right right
over the top and hit him on the top of
the head nah
i'm sorry man
i'm sorry i mean i've seen people get
hit on top of the head and go out i've
seen people get hit on nah
i'm calling bs on that i'm sorry
he rolling around
nah
i'm sorry man i'm sorry
uh that's that's what i'm talking about
is stuff like that that makes you
question the integrity of the sport
because the individual
stumbling around of course if the ref
see you stumbling and bumbling oh okay
i've got to call a fight
nah
i'm sorry i got
oh man i i hate that because i wanted to
see
more from boots in this fight let me see
let me see what's good people
sean thought that
too said i don't like that he got his
bell run
yeah i don't think he got his bell
running
man listen
uh
it is what it is but i'm gonna tell you
this this ain't happening in the last
fight in the last fight
in the main event
castano is there
for
[Music]
glory
charlo is there for glory
you're not going to get
a bs showing from either one of them
i mean
uh
jerome can only do what jurong came to
do and that was win the fight
we knew that uh it would end in a
knockout at some point we thought it
would end in a knockout at some point i
could i think he's on a streak of 18
knockouts
18 straight fights something like that
so
we we figured that it would end in a
knockout
we just wanted uh
an official
honest
effort from clayton and i don't think i
got an honest effort from clayton man
man but i really like this kid i really
like uh jeron so i won't let this taint
his stuff because when he fought lip and
yet that fight that he had with
olympiads was a master class it was a
fantastic fight and olympiads definitely
came to win so i expected that type of
effort um
earnest effort from
clayton but we didn't get that so
hopefully when he fights keith thurman
if he fights keith thurman then it'll be
something incredible that's going to
happen because i think that's a good
fight to contest him and push him to the
next level and see if keith thurman
still got it if he's still one time
keith thurman you know one time is
definitely the best when he was the best
you know
what's going on necromancer
oh man for seven months a king keep up
the great analysis how do you feel about
the current matchmakers of boxing up to
the past boxing era do you feel mma
surpass unboxing
no i think um it's great fights to be
made all across the boards i think mma
has a good
uh monopoly going in the sense that all
that fight is fight under one banner
right so there's no promotional
situations that's uh dividing the
fighters up right and the same thing
with the managers usually their managers
is really all linked into the ufc except
for if you talk about bellator
and and other um
affiliates like that but you know the
main stuff that you do watch is probably
ufc
so that's the difference between box and
boxing you have the pvc you have the
zone you have golden boy and you have
another fraction of promoters across the
boards everybody wants to be a promoter
in boxing right you have
main weather promotions
tank davis promotions earl spins
promotions so you have different
promotions in boxing
that's the problem it's too many
fractions in order to bring everything
together now if everything was under one
banner then you have everybody fighting
everybody but the parity in boxing
leads to
difference in management because of the
dollars
you'll get paid more in boxing than you
would in mma my biggest problem with mma
is
they're not getting paid enough for the
damage that they're receiving these guys
aren't
getting the big bucks
like uh um
uh this uh this guy that fought
mayweather and and and bragging off and
all these other guys they don't receive
a ton of cash like conor mcgregor they
don't receive a ton of cash like that
that's that's an anomaly
right but in boxing if you're in that
top two percent the top three percent
you're garnering a large pay
that's the difference so can they
surpass boxing no they cannot surpass
boxing until
financially
the fighters are supported
y'all all turn out y'all look at ufc we
all see ufc why aren't the fighters
getting paid
these guys have
their careers are very very short
that's my only problem with the ufc they
take hella damage don't get paid enough
and it's in
and i i would love for them to get
paydays like oh four or five million
uh you know they're not doing that
they're getting
thousands
and a lot of fights that y'all see y'all
be very shocked at the purses that these
guys do and they have to pay for their
trainers they have to pay for their
training camp they have to pay for
everybody that's with them
that's not right
boxing structure is different but past
errors in boxing
i love every era of boxing everything is
different
yo you said you're very surprised that
mma makes so little
that's what happens when you have a
monopoly when when you control
everything that's going on
you can dictate price
this being that there's not one
[Music]
avenue to show your fights
and one promoter
then that's where you have bidding wars
for this stuff
so
there there goes the price increases
right
that's not true in mma mma you have a
fight call with 20 fighters and think
about it too in boxing you don't have a
fight card with 20 fighters well you
don't see those fights they're there
they're happening
but that's for the live gates those are
the guys that's fighting for the 5 000
you know for a match and those are the
guys that's fighting four or five times
a year to get the 5 000 here but they
also work in a job you know until they
get to the point where it pops and they
can actually move forward
let me see it came out saying that he
was getting
more money yeah listen
a lot of times these dudes aren't
getting
the money that that's claimed
yeah it's capping everybody's gonna cap
right you gotta you gotta you gotta
front till you get it right right all
right so they walk and drawn back into
the back
tonight's fight
what do we think going into the fight i
did this is
super
walter weight
titles
the unified champion
that is crazy
jamelle has three belt constantly has
won he's trying to get that last belt to
become
the undisputed unified
super
walter weight champion
of the world
that's nuts
castano only has to beat duron i mean uh
jamal to get the bouts
so
this this this is this is a a definitely
a huge test for both fighters it's
everything is on the table right now
this is legacy that's on the table this
is
this is history that's on the table
this is not like the last fight
clayton's like gonna get paid anyway
castano has
argentini he's bringing
his nation with him
and and you know uh jamel is is bringing
the whole houston and united
usa with him
united states with him
that place is
semi-packed
and the fight is coming up the fight is
next we're at it already what time is it
it's only 10 40. usually we saying this
at 11 40 right it's an early night we
got drinks sp what's good with the 5
super chat and this is a great boxing
skills
who do you see giving him a challenge
right now and does he have a chin that's
the question
if he fights keith thurman because
they're talking about him versus keith
thurman next for pay-per-view right if
jerome fights keith thurman we're
definitely going to find out
one thing you could say about keith
thurman he's not a duck he doesn't lay
down he doesn't roll you can't pay him
to give up
um
he has that pride of a champion
he has that will and determination to
push forward so
do do
will innis bring that out will end this
bring that hungry old lion in
you know because right now
uh
ennis is simba
and um
your boy keith thurman is mufasa can he
take him out can he can he scar him
is it possible
i'm gonna tell you right now if keith
thurman landed on his chin can't he take
it and we know keith thurman gonna try
his damn just to touch his chin
so
that's a great fight to see and i hope i
hope they sign that fight i hope that
fight happens i think keith thurman uh
needs to fight some some of the younger
dudes because
in his heyday
he only fought the heyday it's only like
five years ago it's kind of crazy
he only fought his contemporaries danny
porter
you know and those likes but when he was
coming up he was looking for people
you know
so now
we're going to see
if he's willing to fight geron
if jaron is is can't give him
that um that good one that dead that
good fight
and i and i think he can't because i
know juran is coming to fight
that guy's 18 and
18 straight knockouts
jeron
will always bring the fire when he comes
in the ring because you can't teach him
how to lose because he doesn't know how
keith lost
and he knows how to lose because of the
manny pacquiao loss
he knows how to lose there
right so
we just it has to it has to be something
and i think he took manny pacquiao like
and he didn't he didn't test manny
pacquiao manny pacquiao came in there
speeding around that ring i mean
allegedly he's been accused of things we
don't know right but again
man he came in gave him that work
but
ugas
came and beat manny so right now they're
just showing um the first fight
where i thought
jamelle
was lucky
to get that draw
let me tell you man i thought castano
did so much
all right so
and the heaviest shots
was
was was
for jamel
but the more consistent work rate in my
opinion
was um
estanio
so
that's where we have that dynamic right
power versus work rate
what what what does it mean does it mean
that castano is able to uh
put more power into his work rate to get
a better outcome or
does uh jamel
put more
work rate with his power to get his
desired result
i honestly think that um
jamel
can win this fight but at the weigh-in
he looked a little weight drain he came
in two pounds under the weight limit
which is 154
right so
did he over train because remember this
fight was postponed this fight was
originally supposed to happen and
castano something happened to castano
and
they had to postpone a fight
and jamel
waited waited for this fight rightfully
so
so now
they're at the fight did he over train
is he weight drained is is he
did he
train too much for this fight and that's
jamel
because we know castano came in
right on weight ready
so
when they actually get into the ring
what does jamelle have
right now he only has one glove wrapped
right and because they didn't expect
this to happen so early this is what
usually happens you have all your
your your promotions everything and they
expect the fight to go a little bit
longer let me see daniel is not backing
down damn sure he ain't
uh jamela's gonna have to let his hands
go tonight you know he better make let
his hands go because the last time they
fought i said the work weight of castano
was high jamel landed the hardest shots
staniel won the first fight in my
opinion
he was the sharper more accurate fighter
i wouldn't say he was the sharper more
accurate fighter i believe that he was
the busier fighter in that they both
only have one glove uh one hand wrapped
and castano's hand is less wrapped than
uh jamelle
right now so
let me see
thurman needs to
be his next
you're not late man listen man the fight
didn't even start yet you on time baby
what you drinking on
that's the question what you drinking on
today is pina colada day
wait all week to get at least one to two
drinks and that's it a nice and i make
mine
make my own drinks
what they got see
they they don't have anything ready
let me see
just in time hell yeah the main event
gonna start in a minute uh-oh
arrow spencer's in the building
all right so he he's he's he looks a
whole lot better
you know from somebody that was in a
death-defying car accident was in a
fantastic fight not too long ago sp with
the five dollar super chat i see ends
versus thurman right now a great setup
for the next chapter after spins versus
butt yeah because after spence
um and bud
you know spencer's gonna go up and wait
and and fight for the belts that uh
jamel is gonna probably vacate
and
then you have uh his brother
jamal is gonna probably go up to 168 and
and fight um
benavidez right for his belt so
you have all his movement that's going
to happen and the fact that canelo just
lost
and
bevel is talking about going down to
fight canelo for all of his belts
remember because they fought for bibbles
175 belt canelo did and now canelo still
has i think his his four belts is he
undisputed in that division or does he
is he missing one i don't know if he's
undisputed in a division i have to check
but um no i think he became undisputed i
think he yeah he became undisputed in
that division
so
um bevel wants to go down and fight him
for his belts
he said king is am i a bartender no i'm
not a bartender i could be but i won't
stand inside no
uh no club making drinks for anybody
but i would help you out on how to make
a good drink
so
they're they're talking to arrow spins
they have to fill the time they have to
fill the gaps remember they have whole
promotional ties that they have to do so
they have to stretch it out a little bit
so we got a little bit right before the
fight guys we got 38 guys in here with
33 likes let's get more the rest of
those likes up there let's just average
out a little bit
i think there's gonna be fight of the
year
yeah yo
see i don't ever talk about fights
really up until that day
right so right now you're just getting
in some filler stuff right to to actual
other fights but
i usually watch the weigh-in because i
get reports on what they're doing in
training camp and stuff like that right
yeah everybody gets those right if you
actually know some people you can get
that
but then
when they get to the scale the scale
don't lie the scale tells the truth the
scale tells if you work too hard or work
too little if you had an injury in
or if you didn't or if you didn't have a
proper nutrition if you didn't spend
your money right if you
the the scale tells it all can't hide
from the scale
now
now that they're there
now we can have a fight now we can have
a conversation
all these dudes do speculations and all
this other stuff and the fights never
happen
so they make all this content just to
have something to talk about with you
all i want to do i'm the professional
fan
all i want to do is have some drinks
talk about the fight that we're seeing
and my boxing intellect we can
decipher what's going on we can have a
common interest in what's happening with
these fights right what we expect so
him being weight drink he looked
a little uh gout his his face looked a
little drawn in
um
how does he look tonight he looked a
little better when he was wrapping his
hands his chest didn't look
uh
as as as pronounced as i would have
liked it right so maybe he's not lifting
any weights at all in this training camp
and you know sometimes uh you don't want
to have your fighter lift weights
because a lot of
um
trainers believe that
it restricts their movement their
freedom of movement so
they have more of a swimmer's regimen to
be honest with you all a biker's
regiment or a runner's regiment compared
to a weight lifter's regiment
let me see all hell eye a piece of loot
that's right joe mac blessings brother
grown man night king are you watching
the
jim gray spin oh yeah i'm watching i'm
watching it right now i was watching the
jim gray spence interview
yeah
yo
this this is this is out of control i'm
not even gonna go into
who did they make up for showtime and
who got these dudes ready this is this
is not just
no no
no no no no no not like this
no no oh my god
yo it was no way i mean hey listen i did
my bed before the fight right i did my
little just for men you understand
did that when when i get a little bit
older then i'm just gonna let it rock
and be mike tyson in the face
but um
brother nah you don't do the smooth face
yo all right so what he did
what he did right
what he did is he got the powder on his
face right like you know how to do the
powder puff
makeup right
he did that that's one of the
announcements right and he got his hair
dyed so his hair is jet black right and
his skin looked extra white so he looked
like a vampire talking to the other dude
but then he don't have no mustache and
no bed he's just out here with naked
face
so you look like a naked face vampire
i'm dead i can't i can't take it
i can't take it then you got a little
dude over there to look like me when on
sunday when i'm wearing my shades it's
crazy as hell
nah
no no no no no no no no
[Laughter]
it's impossible
it's about al bernstein i know al
bernstein is just looking at these dudes
like what the hell what's going on
i love al bernstein he's probably one of
the realest dudes left at showtime
um
he gives dope assessments uh i never
liked when they brought this guy and he
seen the other guy he seems like a
wrestler i don't even know his name he
seems like he uh
does a wrestling commentary but that
that smooth face right there now you
gotta throw a mustache on that beat
you can't be walking around with the
vladimir face
he looks like
vlad the impaler this is out of control
yo that is sickening let me see
yo
so who who what what y'all got who y'all
got
who you got tonight because i can't look
at the vampire dude
who do you got tonight do you got
castano do you got uh
jamelle
uh put a one in there for jamel put a
two in there for castano and put a three
for a draw if we go get another draw
are they gonna fight that hard did they
they get a draw or what is it gonna be
so let me see what y'all got what y'all
got going on in there
this is crazy
all right so we got uh two
two one
all right
he said elisa tea
tell the truth shay the devil
lisa goatee
all right all right so we got a lot of
twos a lot of a lot of ones
looks kind of split got another drawers
out they got some drawers out there
huh
look a little look a little split
see that's how you know it's a good
fight
when the crowd is split
that's how you know it's a good fight
who's the what's the last statue oh i
got a couple of statues upstairs i
actually i got four statues being sent
to me to be honest with you um i'm just
waiting for a friend of mine to get his
is his his stuff
whatever he had ordered a whole bunch of
statues so i'm waiting for that to go
because i got a statue to ship to him
and he's sending me a whole bunch of
statues so
um uh combat i mean kos is coming back
uh
and king of the statues is coming back
and that's coming back as a live show as
well and i'm gonna do a whole bunch of
stuff with that
in giving you that content right so but
we're gonna be doing live unboxings uh
we're gonna be doing raffles we're gonna
be doing giveaways we're gonna have a
lot of promotions and those statues i
got there i got like two statues right
here right now i got one right here and
got one right here that i didn't even
unbox yet um finishing up the the other
room uh
to be honest with you combat talk wasn't
even supposed to be in this room combat
talk was supposed to be in the upstairs
room uh same thing with the kos
so
we working on certain things because
like i told you before i want these
shows to be call-in shows i want you
guys to interact so instead of me asking
you put one in the chat put two in the
chat stuff like that we talking on the
phone
this is what i want i want to have that
rapport with you guys so we're gonna
build and we're gonna grow we're gonna
take this to the next level all day
yeah jerome's with the ko
oh
he said king would catch the gemini
great watch thank you so much man um
me and cash is mad cool like um statue
community is dope
statue community
it it's
it's it's friends and family it's it's
dope
so that interview i definitely wanted to
do we was trying to get to that
interview i got a huge interview uh
tomorrow
with uh fonz
and
and yo if y'all didn't know if y'all
don't know now
um david jaffe is gonna be on iop
tomorrow
i um
really love that dude because
the playstation love that i have
for him
y'all y'all get a chance to hear it
tomorrow
uh i only had a couple of people on my
bucket list that i've ever wanted to
interview and he's definitely
one of the dudes on top of that list to
be honest with you i probably have like
four dudes
that i really wanted to you know have a
conversation with them and pick their
mind
for people
and um
shout out to laura cognito and attic for
being as diligent as they was and
definitely funds really for
uh getting david jaffe on
because he has a special place in my
heart and and he should have a special
place in every playstation dude's heart
he said i need at least one uh dc statue
i got three dc stuff actually i got four
i got superman batman wonder woman and i
got aquaman
actually i gotta take aquaman out the
box and put him up six i was putting
them for sale but
nobody was buying so i'm just going to
take it and just put it upstairs with
the rest of them let me see
you enjoyed that interview thank you
brother
he said i'm trying to save all my iop
talk for tomorrow yeah yeah yeah
definitely do
um we we
yo these they they work so hard man i i
can't lie i got to tell you man cognito
and attic as far as as as getting
the the people on
really really
my hat is always taking off to them
hayachi face
it's always taking off to them man
because they they they go above and
beyond um in getting these interviews so
anytime you see me and you'd be like yo
you're kidding okay you funny as hell
trying my best to keep up with they work
great they work great it's crazy
mewtwo comic arcs
uh banner war and judgment day all right
yo so the fact that thor versus the hulk
and they doing a big spread remember
back in the days when you used to read
thor versus the hulk right and well you
get a book and it'd be just like one
book and then the next book it would
just be uh the continuation of the fight
or the fighters they they introduced him
with the last splash page and then the
next book is the fight then the fight is
over in that book right now what they're
doing is they're doing the arc right now
where the hawk is going to fight
thor through a series of books through
the alpha and omega of it i think it's
crazy because
they have different power sets right now
thor is really super strong his hammer
is imbued with the soul of odin right
that's crazy in saying that but by
itself right but then you you you go
over and the hawk is being controlled by
banner so in his brain is nuts but um
they're trying all right so it's it's
the sun is setting right now in cali i
guess that's cali
and um
right now the fight is getting ready i
know they're getting warmed up in the
background
and
they're about to get busy
oh man brian custer he
sharp
my man always looks sharp all right so
they're at the weigh-in and castano
looks great at the weigh-in i'm not
lying he looks perfect at the wind
smiling
flexing
jamal is chewing right now but he came
in two pounds lighter right
and i'm
he's flexing he's moving
he has a lot of animation a lot of
energy
but if you're looking anytime they have
those shoes those chooses to bring back
to to
to to help them start to get their their
weight back up after they because they
their weight drain at this time they
dried out so he dried out at this period
of time to make weight he didn't even
have to because he was two pounds under
and they should have been checking that
the whole week they should have been
checking his weight the whole week so i
don't know if he went to the bathroom
right before or whatever but two pounds
you're not gonna lose two pounds in the
bathroom you know so that's a little bit
of a concern for me uh in this fight and
i tell you i look at the weight so right
now cassano
is there they're checking his shorts
both gloves is um both hands are wrapped
and he's stretching excuse
me so he doesn't have his gloves on yet
and he's putting his gloves on now
all right
rest in peace goat perez
suicide kings travel to the legend let's
see
what you mean rest in peace george perez
pass
oh my god please don't say that please
don't say that please don't say that
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god
rest in peace george perez oh my god
yo he was one of the greatest artists of
of my time
he did crisis on infinite earths
i mean he did he did a lot of books
infinity uh gauntlet
um some of those issues
man
man george george perez
you know what his claim to fame was like
he could draw groups of people right
and
everybody had an individual look in the
in the individual face
uh sp for two super chat hit that like
button that's what's up
um we got 40 people we got 39 we got uh
there we go we got 43 people we got uh
40 likes
that's what's up um
yes
george perez listen
i love john byrne i love john romita
junior
uh
todd mcfarlane would kill me if i didn't
tell you that i loved him um george
perez ron lim
uh jim lee
jack kirby
all these great dudes all these great
dudes
steve ditko
all these great dudes but man to to
to lose a living legend
that's that's something that man i
didn't know
that's yo i listen i work a lot man i
work a ton and then i come home and i
and i work a ton trying to you know
trying to come up with content trying to
do things
and um
man that's that's a blow that that that
hurts
uh rest in peace george perez that
that's that's a blow
damn
oh boy but we are back with this vampire
talking to al bernstein
al bernstein look like they they they
suck the blood out of him too pulse
hey
oh
neil adams definitely
one of the best
what
are you serious
oh hell no
come on man don't say that
all right guys yo let's let's let's
let's let's let's let's let's get let's
get back to the fights
let's um
because i'm gonna i'm gonna have enough
with uh kos for you guys a ton of stuff
trust me i got a ton of a ton of stuff
and i gotta reflect
salute
to george perez
and arthur adams
wow
that's that's kind of crazy man
that is out of control
let me see what we're going on there my
apologies king no problem
no problem man no problem listen man we
all here listen this is a whole
conversation
we're having a whole conversation right
before the fight there is no fight right
now
but um
we we do have you know some boxing this
evening and we're going to have one hell
of a fight because both fighters look
like they're coming to win like i said
if i saw anything any indication of
anything
leading into this right now is the fact
that he came in um
excuse me jamelle
two pounds under the 154 weight limit
and castano came in i think was uh 153
153 and a half
so he's right on weight
that means they was meticulous with
watching his weight all the way through
up until the hour before he's about to
to get on the scale so
it's it's little things like that that
uh
get the win
the attention to detail well how
dedicated is your team how dedicated is
your trainer how dedicated is your
nutrition is how how dedicated are you
right because it all boils down to the
fighter right
so
at the end of the day we know castano's
dead to to hit and be hit he's there to
fight
and they talking to llq right now
this is this is absolutely crazy they
didn't expect that this fight was a beat
was to be right now it's 11 o'clock and
usually the main events is 11 30 and
better right
what we get out of here what at 12
o'clock usually my wife always had that
face let me see hard work dedication
definitely
tyson in his prime versus alley in his
prime
in the past i was ignorant right i was
ignorant to all the ability of iron mike
tyson and we're talking about iron mike
tyson right here right we're not talking
about kid dynamite we're not talking
about mighty mike tyson we're talking
about iron mike tyson right
okay iron mike tyson versus
uh muhammad ali we're not talking about
cassius clay we're talking about
muhammad ali right we're talking about
muhammad ali before he went to jail
right
because i can give you three scenarios i
can give you cassius clay versus kid
dynamite
cassius k fought sonny liston kid
dynamite uh that was before he fought
trevor burbick for his first title right
cassius clay versus kid dynamite cash's
clay beats kid dynamite
all right muhammad ali
versus iron mike tyson you're talking
about muhammad ali right before he went
to incarceration
versus
muhammad um i am mike tyson that fort
trevor burbik
right
before mike went to jail
so this is both pre-jail
muhammad ali
in a hard fought
15 round
decision
because they were going 15 rounds then
right
okay
both
after jail
both after jail so you got muhammad ali
after he comes out of jail that's before
he does the thrill in manila
and um mike tyson after jail before he
fights peter mcnealy
i give
mike the slight
advantage
there
even though you would say that the the
alleged substance abuse or emitted
substance abuse from mike
uh
that precipitated him actually getting
to the whole incarceration and all that
other stuff
and muhammad ali we don't know uh what
his vices was up until that point right
until after that part so i got to give
mike
going to the distance with ali
at that period of time and that'll be a
12-round fight because we're going with
michael who's the other one was ali rule
so
i i will give i will give mike and i
don't think mike knocks out uh muhammad
ali because muhammad ali fought with a
broken jaw so i don't think mike knocks
him out but i think mike does enough
damage in that fight to actually
probably even maybe stagger ali
um
because look joe frazier knocked him
down right and now that was that was
right after
uh he stood in jail right but then he
came back and gave joe frazier the
warping of his life
um
so yeah i got to go with mike on that so
again so that'd be two that'd be two to
one
take mike tyson body shots and uppercuts
cut him down ko now
there's not gonna be no ko
he's not gonna ko ali
at all
you
if you really think that mike with ko
ali please go back and watch old ali
fights please go back and watch that
stuff i mean this
listen a young cassius clay went up
against the most dangerous heavyweight
in in in the history of boxing in my
opinion in sunny listing
all right a young cassius clay was out
of his mind
that's why he would have beat kid
dynamite because the young cassius clay
was out of his mind no
trust me go watch a young caster's clay
fight he's absolutely ridiculous with
his skills insane all right so jamal
charlo is uh right there like i told you
like guys listen his chest lacks the
definition that i would expect from his
chest to have
right um
his abs lacked the definition that i
expect his abs to have
uh
but again it's it could be
this training camp that has
uh
jamel
looking a little soft but he could be
his brother's deal with him he could be
just what he ate to
uh
rehydrate
so
okay all right so we we expect we
experience we expect a huge a huge fight
here
i i just um i
i don't know if he did more push-ups
i don't know what he did
but you look he's looking a little bit
um a little bit a little bit slimmer
than i expected and then i want i got to
see
castano to tell you coming in but
what do i what do i expect for this
fight who do i got going in this fight
like i said jemele's a slight favorite
uh does his power translate did he
overtrain and didn't doesn't have the
power
right
hmm
could be could be not i think honestly
that the power does translate i do think
maybe
uh we get a 12 round decision with uh
jamel uh coming out winning do i think
jamel stops him
that's crazy
when he had him in trouble the last
fight and i want you to go back to that
because he caught us daniel at least two
to three times
severely when he had him in trouble
he wasn't able to put him out
i don't think
unless it's a uh uh a snapping hook
that is not a check left hook that is
like out of the blue
catches them
i don't expect it
all right so can it can cassano
castano outwork them yeah cause then you
can outwork them but is it is it going
to be the part tonight is is tonight
gonna be the night where
jamel doesn't allow cassandra to push
him to the ropes and he stands in the
middle of the ring and he dictates the
fight because if he allows castano to
push him back then that's then this
fight is for the grabbings and i believe
constantly can win the fight but if
jamal
actually i mean jamel actually goes in
and walks him down and pushes him back
and dictates the fight i think jamel
couldn't win
um a 12-round decision
yeah you know i need to see them step in
the ring what i'm saying is i see jamal
looking for a knockout yeah
i think both of them is looking for the
knockout
i think sp i think i think jamel is
looking for the knockout and i think
it's daniel's looking for the knockout
i don't think either one of them walked
away from the first fight
with the um outcome
satisfactory see look
castano
is moving nice
and sharp in the back uh as he's hitting
the mitts
you know um
this this this is this is this is
something
to behold here because we have a fighter
that has been in the ring
with jamel
and
he's eager to get back in
to continue where they left off at
so
this this is this is something
to behold i love
the dynamic between the two one is a box
a puncher and one is a boxer brawler
right a puncher a puncher brawler
type of thing but he has some skill to
him because daniel has skill to him so
don't think he
and he's not um a mexican fighter talk
about because somebody was hitting me
with oh he he does mexican style
all right
so all right
they got uh
jamelle's uh robe on
so he's getting ready to walk out right
now castano i think comes out first
and i think castano is holding up
everything
kale on round six
yeah see
cassano is moving around nice and fluid
so
y'all ever notice how uh jermel always
has his head tilted to the side
always that's how i can tell the two
between the the difference between the
two one always have his head tilted and
the other one is always straight up
that's how i can tell the difference
between the two
all right so he's dealing with his
brother his brother is the 160 pound
champion that's jamal
jamel is the one
uh 54 champion three belt um haver
all right so now estanio is coming out
and there and and then and they're ready
so we're getting ready to get to the
main event right now they get ready to
walk out we done did it
listen
jemele always looks nervous
don't don't ever
don't ever go by his facial impres his
facial uh reactions don't ever go by
that don't don't use that as impressions
to to judge where he is he always has
that same look like a worried kid at
school
always does
but gets in the ring and turns into a
whole beast his brother has a different
a different
relaxed demeanor
completely different
not the same this one
he always like you know has the eyes up
and he always has to look don't go by
that don't because i was fooled by that
do not be fooled by that that dude is
always fight ready 100 now the place is
sold out now the place is packed i know
i see some seats out in the back so they
probably didn't sell a venue out
uh with that and that sucks because this
fight right here is better than a lot of
fights that's on pay-per-view
this is definitely
uh better than what keith thurman's
fight that he had uh
with uh
um uh mario's barrios
yes yes yes
look but he held off because he always
liked it
don't don't don't don't go by that look
that that them boys raised the fight man
young boy is raised to fight
something crazy
all right so here we go
see look look even
even in the pictures
he has that that nervous look like
he always looks like he up to no good
you know you got that one kid you go
inside the room like what y'all doing he
always got that huh
he always got that look so he always and
every time you always checking his
pockets making sure he ain't up to no
good hey man what you got your hand
what's going on boy
so right now
right before they walking out to the
ring because they have to do the whole
safety check thing right before they go
down the hole so they have to make sure
that there's nothing there's nothing
going in they're showing you a clip of
uh jamel right now
and he's showing you
a clip of castano
so
we're getting to the fight
right and this is the last safety
protocols because they can't have no
issues when these dudes just coming down
the aisle and you know coming down the
hallways they checking all the doors
going through and all that other stuff
and making sure the people there that
are supposed to be there walking them
down out so
it wasn't me
all right so
here we go
all right so
they're going in and they showing all
the fights that they had
and i'm gonna tell you man uh jamel
hits like a brick house
hits like a brick house i don't know
what they feed in these dudes in texas
but they hit
hard
okay they hit hard i don't know what
they're training on what's going on
but them boys hit hard
so
we we're going to get a good one right
now
and and
i remember
when um
all the fights that they're showing now
and and and jamelle is an absolute
monster he has that concerned face but
he's an absolute moss and i you know
what let me tell you something
to be
great you always got to have a little
bit of fear
you always got to have that fear riding
on their shoulder that keeps you aware
that keeps you
in the pocket because those dudes that
have no fear that's the night they get
knocked out the night they have no fear
let me see
shawn my armor brat
got it working
cody that's yo i'm not even gonna
support that charlo by k.o here we go
i'm not even gonna support that
king would you let the
announcer sit on your couch with all
that dye on his head
on my couch which one you talk about my
red couch
in my red room
or are you talking about uh the the gray
regular smegula i let them sit on my on
coco's couch with all that dye on and
say well i can't be i can't be shaming
the dude because i got dog i died my
baby
come on man we ain't gonna do that we
ain't gonna be out here
die shaming dudes and i tell y'all every
iron lords i gotta make sure the beard
has died
get out of here with that we're gonna
shout but i'ma tell you he had the ball
face though what was doing it dirty was
his face was bold
oh you got to give it up to his
argentinian behind he got a rapper with
him
he outside son he outside castano is
coming to the ring with his own rapper
this is what's up he's like nah you know
um
gonna bring my boy from the club you
know i'm gonna have him out there spit
some balls as i go through
yo yo yo yo
stop that with all that let the gray go
not gonna happen not yet i'm not willing
to let it go i'm a toys r us kid i don't
want to grow up ass get away from me
you'll see yo my wife was shaving me to
date
cause she went to go do something and
she was like oh look at that gravy a bit
i said oh it's about to be gone by the
time you see me get out of here
[Laughter]
i i yo i don't know if it's bad but i uh
my wife would know about that
i'm i'm having a hard time uh keeping up
with the rappers
little little
little half dead in the rest of them
little slime man
now i'm cool i'm cool on that
all right so castano's in the ring and
he brought his belt is that the wbo
or the ibf which one is that
all right and here we go
jemele is coming through
he he quickly turned this into a united
states versus argentina
this is kind of crazy
okay
he come with his brother
no frills only scales
a little slime man
only skills
jamella's in here only skills skills
pays the bills
we outside now they dropped their lights
down low shot the lights down
now he got an old school robe they don't
even make robes like that no more
that joint right there's he he had to
capture a whole alligator and a couple
of pythons
yeah
see he he got the look
of the kid that don't want to listen you
saw when the referee was talking to him
and he was just like he had the head
tilt to the side he got that that look
yeah you see listen man i'm telling you
he he he's scared don't be concerned
with him he got that i don't wanna
listen look
that that hard-headed kid look
and i know i know all y'all grew up with
some one kid that was inside your
neighborhood there was that hard-headed
kid that didn't want to listen
there's no build up like the
championship boxing match that's right
there ain't no build up like that
he said he went to africa to go get his
robe yo you crazy
[Laughter]
yeah
he was wrestling alligators
[Laughter]
yo
he had to die in his pocket so when he
got the elevator alligator down on the
floor he rubbed a red dye on him first
all right so you know jamel is a 511
with a 73 arm reach advantage castano is
5'7 with his 68 arm um
on reach
already know
we already know that we already know
that castano is the shorter fighter we
already know that uh jemele is the
taller fighter we already know that he
has the distance
and um castano cuts distance
he knows how to cut off the ring
that's what makes this so intriguing you
know castano knows how to fight knows
how to box
knows how to put his body in positions
where he's going to be uh advantageous
is advocation for him to win
same thing with jemele
jamal knows how to fight and we found
out in the last fight that they had that
jamal can fight going backwards so
that's where the big intrigue is at
so they're introducing both of them
right now in the middle of the ring
and it's about to get on
because daniel looks happy he looks
smiling
okay
all right
just get to the part where i said let's
get ready to rumble
all right glenn fieldman
david sullivan and zachary young
zachary young is from california you
gotta watch that dude never heard of him
before
oh
all right so the referee is jerry cantu
never heard of him either might be a
knockout
let me see
definitely not bad bunny
he said he fought mufasa force
mufasa don't got no alligator skin get
out of here
you're crazy
here we go we on it we on it right now
all right so the fight get ready start
they introducing castano
i'm surprised they didn't do the
national anthem
that's kind of crazy because they were
supposed to do the national i don't know
maybe they did it earlier tonight i have
absolutely no idea
brian castano's record is 17-0
with uh two uh
17 no uh decisions two losses
12 wins by way of knockout
i mean no um
two decisions i mean two draws
no uh no no losses
12 knockouts
pretty decent record
his wife is there
cheering them on
they put the mouthpiece in
and jamelle is there with his brother
his trainer trainer of the year actually
be honest with you if he can get his
fighter to win tonight
34 and one with one uh draw with 18 wins
by ko
and that dictates that he's a boxer by
nature
uh
jemele is a boxer by nature
you know we have 18 big wins by kale but
the ratio is 34 his fights
so that means he doesn't go for the ko
the whole time
so i don't i don't know that that that
anything indicates a lot
so
is a constantly
more of a puncher
wreck it would indicate so
let me see
oh thank you thank you phase 114 114
that's right we in here
let's go
let's go all right so they bring them
closer in the middle of the ring
estany was first there
uh charlo just came in cassani is
staring at him charlo staring at him
they got that look
all right castano looks a little bit
fleshed out
charlo looks a little bit fleshed out
taller
i still don't like charlo's how how his
body is setting i don't know but i still
got um
charlo about 12 round decision getting
all belt
if it is a knockout that'll be crazy
and
round one
is about to start that place is packed
here we go ain't nothing like a
heavyweight fight let's go
so right now they're in the center of
the ring
nobody's throwing anything
so they're just looking at each other
again
so castano is doing phantom jabs
and
jamel isn't giving up ground
castano
threw
a one-two at the air
again he's reaching with his jab
estanio is
jamelle is doing the same
jamel throws a one-two
block by castano in the center of the
ring both of them they're just fainting
fainting is when you
move your body your shoulder without
throwing a punch uh to fake like you are
they're both doing fainting jabs in the
center of the ring castano's given
distance jamel throws a one two and a
three under the ribs to castano castano
steps in with the jab still in the
center of the ring here i might i add
all right so
we got uh castano throwing the one two
jamel's staying on his stick staying on
the jab
castano now is stepping up the pressure
doing one two to the body one two three
um jamel countess him with a one two of
his own
jamel is back to stabbing him in the
body with the jab and bringing it up top
because daniel
is throwing a one two
missing
both shots
center the ring
all right castano goes low comes back up
nothing fainting fainting
all right and jamelle is back to stick
in the jab
standing throws a one-two misses
and jamel is there throwing a one-two
castano tried to hit jamel he pushing
jamel back one two three
and castano and jamel castagna just hit
jamel with a good shot jamel was off
balance
and castaneda thought he had something
there i think that was fool's gold
jamel is trying to catch him with the
check left hook coming in because daniel
caught him with a jab
walking him back jab again from castano
is throwing the jab in the right hand
jamel is going under the rib cage with a
left hook
jab right hand in the center of the ring
and
they're back in the center of the ring
again
you have uh one two from jamel castano
throws a knife right
and hits jamel
back again in the center of the ring
get a jab right hand one two three from
jamal
castano tries to push it but jamel
actually lands the better shots in the
first round
that that round can go to either or i
would give the round to jamel over the
simple fact that he gave more
in that round to be honest with you i
think he gave more
i think he um
threw more digging shots to the body i
think he uh counted more with his right
hand and his jab
castano did try to stop uh step in and
when constant did step in uh he did do
some work
uh he caught him off guard
excuse me jamel
but uh it wasn't too much
yeah both are following each other
around uh
in the ring
all right so they get ready to start
again
and right now we have uh
no one's rushing into the middle of the
ring yet
they're both in respective corners
they meet in the center of the ring
what do we have here jemele pumping the
jab pumping the jab pumping the jab
pumping the jab oh
right hand strong to the body jamelle
throws a double left hook
back to the jab
castanya throws a right hand over the
top tries to catch jamelle
and i think jamel is there for the right
hand
to be honest with you and he see here uh
cassanya just caught jemele with the
right hand and i think he's there for
the right hand because he drops his his
left
jamel is throwing two to three shots up
the middle
to catch castano when he comes in but
he's throwing it off for his back foot i
don't think he
is throwing it with conviction
to be honest with you so all right so
now we have uh castano
uh
step into jamel
and again remember i told you jamel had
to push castano back castano is still
pushing jamelle back
he's still uh giving him that constant
pressure jamelle hits more to 1-2 tries
to back him off
standing comes right back stays in the
pocket
uh jabs into the body tries to throw a
right hand over the top casino is still
there comfortable and relaxed
um moving from side to side
showing movement
jamel throws a jab
and a right hand and tries to throw the
uppercut the same combination he's been
trying to land since round run and he
caught castano with a straight right
hand and a left hook right now
uh castano better be careful
with what he's doing right now
uh castano is back in the center of the
ring high guard
while jamel
uh caught a left to the body
and went to reach that was an awkward
scene
uh constantine throws the right hand
over the top
jamel throws a left hook and a left
uppercut
jab
from jamelle
castane is there high guard in center of
the ring pushing jamal back tries to
throw the left hand and the right
he lands the right a lot
aggressively so
so you have uh jamel throwing jabs again
in the center of the ring
steps back shoots the jab castano is
still pressuring him
and pushing the left hook to the body
of jamelle
jamel throws a left hook and an uppercut
kastanya thrives tries her right hand
jamal looks off balance or something
castano jamel throws a right hand over
the top
and castano digs oh
jamel
castano with a right hand
and he steps back castano catches him
with a 1-2
and jemele didn't look good at the end
if i'm going to give anything to that
round i'm going to have to say who would
i rather be in that round i would have
rather been castano even though castano
took up um
two punches
i thought that
uh
castano landed some of the better shots
in that round now jamel landed that
beautiful left hook off of a counter
but again it's it's it's
his legs aren't looking right
i feel like it's one one to be honest
with you
and um
castano is doing great work the right
hand is going to be a telling blow for
the evening
and
i and i think
jamel has to be concerned with the with
the right hand from castano because he's
landing at a frequency that is he
shouldn't be landing at
so all right so they're back round three
cassania starts off with a left hook it
uh doesn't hit
jamel is back on his back foot again
throwing jabs in the center of the ring
and he's uh
and castano tries to slide in with a
left hook because he's trying to set up
jamel for the right hand
all right so what you do is you give
your opponent the left hook and he hits
him again with the right hand i think
jamel is there for the right hand this
whole evening
all right so castano pushes up jamelle
up against the ropes throws a one two
short hooks
in close
and
jamel is back to jabbing and sent to the
ring after the rest breaks them up and
he swings wildly and misses jamelle
all right castano ties him up
and it goes back to a jab and jamel goes
right back to the body and shoots the
jab down the
middle he's giving him a lot of lateral
movement
a lot of lateral movement
jabs he's trying to keep his back off
the ropes jamelle is while castano keeps
hitting him with that same right hand
doesn't matter if it's looping doesn't
matter if it's straight doesn't matter
he still hits him with that right hand
and jamel is back to the jab and um
castano is back to stalking
and cutting off the ring
good left hook from jamelle
and right back to the body
and back to the jab he's putting in good
work and he hits him with a right hand
and he gave uh castano uppercut but he
constantly went straight to the body of
jamel
it's a lot of action
and it's very high contested boxing
right so
they're they're right now swinging
castano caught jamel with a left hook
and jamela's back his back is getting
closer to the ropes he's jabbing the
stanley catches them with a right hand
i'm
i'm telling you i don't like the right
hands that castano keeps catching jamel
with jamel is throwing double and triple
jabs and a straight right hand uppercut
and right hand to castano face and he
steps away castano lands his right hand
and doesn't want to be tied up
and jamelle is jabbing and jabbing while
castano is stalking trying to land a
right hand a left hook the stadium is
trying to land
while jamel is against the ropes and he
lands a one two
and jamel throws a one two to step to
get him back off but castano stays in
the pocket jamel is trying to land the
right hand straight but he's
telegraphing it
castano is still there pressing him
uh jamel throws a one two three to back
castano off castenia's back in the
pocket pressing him
constant pressure round is over give
that round to jamelle
what's going on flame so uh it's two to
one
i give that round to jamel
you always got to ask yourself the
question who would you rather be at the
end of that round and that let you know
exactly who would you rather be right i
would rather be uh jamelle at the end of
that round
so i give that round to jamel
you know very very very good high
contested round jamelle landed some
shots constantly landed some shots
i think castano's key to his victory is
castano's right hand
to be honest with you
but uh jamel has to do double hooks to
the body
in order to work his daniel he has to
throw a jab
sell out to the body one two
to the body both hands to the body
dig the body and um
work him back
because
i'm telling you
castano is there to fight
this is the difference between the last
uh last fight in this fight so we had
round four jamel caught um cassano
coming in
with a short uppercut
here we go
they're back in the center of the ring
jabbing
one two
castano is fainting trying to uh to get
a break in the guard jamal throws uh two
uh one two up top
and castano shoots a straight right
one two from charlo
that's a jab to the body and a right
hand over the top they're they're
swinging at each other and they're
trading blows so castano is throwing
short hooks while jamel is throwing one
two long shots
they're both doing it while
jamelle is uh straight right hand from
castano hits jamel
while he's up against the ropes and he
tries a left hook right hand combination
he missed all the shots
while jamel was weaving
jamel is back up against the ropes
throwing uh
jabs
and
estanio
is on him
all right so they're back to jabbing
castano is walking him down throwing
jabs
and right hands
he's going to catch him with a left hook
inside
uh
and
jamel slides out
and he throws a jab catches castano
while he was dipping
back to the jabs
straight jabs
oh nice left hook
nice right hand from castano
to my legs doesn't look like great
castano went to the body and went to the
head
all right and jamal goes right back to
castano's body and catches him with a
left hook and a one-two all right
castano goes in jamal catches them with
a left
they're still they're there to be hit
castano is throwing in the center of the
ring
jamelle is back to jabbing backing off
castano is back to stalking
looking like a young caesar chavez
here we go again
nice uppercut from castano jamel is back
on his jab
and castano is pushing him back
all right jamel goes to grab
and castano pushes him off and goes
right to the body and he's throwing
punches while jamela's up against the
rope and jamel is looking for counters
as he steps to the left and castano
catches him with a straight right
and jamel catches him with a 1-2 these
dudes are throwing heavy lever but
castano catches them with a straight and
jamelle catches him with a left hook oh
end of that round uh castano is out on
his foot yo castano got hit with one
hell of a shot at the end of that round
there was so much action going on you
had a lot of uh give and take throughout
the whole round
and at the end of that round i'm gonna
have to be uh charlo all right
they're standing there castano is
getting the better of the inside shots
with the shorter hands right
but when jamel steps out and he throws a
left and a right he catches castano he
caught castano right there at the end of
the round with a powerful left hook
that is kind of crazy the fight could be
over if if if his legs is in the back if
he don't have recuperative skills in the
middle of this round right now they have
to do something right now spit out a
mouthpiece uh uh
take off a little of of the tape
is daniel's standing up in the middle
ring he turns around he looks at his
corner
like
and he's out there
he has a little wealth under his uh left
eye i believe and jamelle is back in the
center of the ring pushing the um
the the the fight
castano's walking him down very smart
don't give him that you
are weakened or you're not all the way
there
all right
one two from uh castano catches jamelle
jamel goes underneath with an uppercut
to the body and castano catches him with
a right hand jamal catches him with a
left hook
i see that jamal is more eager to uh
hold while castano isn't
cassani is there to do work
jamal
will not
get to hold
castano get caught with a 1-2
off the ropes and jamal takes him right
back in the center of the ring stiff
jabs
stiff jabs and he's ready in the right
hand stiff jabs and he's ready in the
right hand and castano shoots
the
jab
and he chases him with the left hook
all right so
they're back there
again to the ropes
and this is where all the work is done
you know cassania throws short left
hooks right hands and
jamel catches him with a left hook off
the ropes the same left hook he caught
him with the last round he caught him
again with it now
so gets gastano gets to do all the work
but
uh jamel catches him with shots in
between
and right now i don't think uh castano
is all the way there
to be honest with you jamel hits him
with a one-two castano keeps stalking
him and going straight to his body
right hand
castano tries it
and he steps away
jamel is moving a lot more in this round
a lot more show of himself with his feet
and castano is still stalking him he's
not cutting off the ring he's just
following him now
usually he can stand and cuts off the
ring he's not cutting off the ring
so they're both trading shots one twos
and he just caught jamal with a short
left and a right hand
and he caught him with a left up against
rope and then he going to jamel body
caught jamel with a one-two to the face
jamal caught him with a one-two back up
against the ropes and they're landing
and trading shots
one left hook one right hand one jab one
left hook focus daniel one right hand
from charlo
jab from charlo
and
right hand left hook from castano
castano got caught with a 1-2 jamel is
stalking him in the corner hitting him
with shots
again jemele is walking him down one two
to the head and castano comes back jamel
catches him with a left and castano
comes back to fight castano is throwing
shots cassano is selling out castano is
not taking that
if i had to pick a person to be i would
be castano at the end of that round i'ma
tell you it was give and take up until
that point and i thought that charlo
would have got that round but then
castano comes in at the end of that
round and castano puts the fire just
when he got the pressure put on him
castano puts the pressure back on
jamelle
oh my god that was one hell of a round
i'm not gonna lie i'm i'm at 2-2 here uh
so far this is this is some even steven
stuff this is delicious fighting i can't
lie
they're a perfect match that's that's
this is that's exactly it uh sp they are
a perfect match for each other this is
exactly what we're talking about in the
round this is this is what you want to
see you want to see matchmaking made
like this these are two champions and
they fight for undisputed right here
they're giving no quarter no quarters
given nothing is taken everything is
earned
oh man this is it right here
all right so they back in the center of
the ring
oh no so yeah yeah i give it a 3-2 sorry
three-two
three to jamelle uh two-two um
lasagna
round six
oh castano keeps throwing that right
hand very beautiful anytime you get to
jamella complain you know you hit him
with a good shot
all right so castano's coming in he he's
heating up
and he's getting hit by these left hooks
from jamal but he's shooting the right
hand
so
it's either is going to eat the left
hook i mean eat the right hand and
cassani's going to eat the left hook
i think jamel should have just practiced
on the left hook all day long
toughening up that that punch
because right now castano is stalking
the old castano just got caught with two
left hooks that was insane castano tries
a left hook of his own and he misses and
he jabs
and jamelle isn't giving castano
anything to work off of
i've noticed that jamel gets castano in
trouble but backs off him
to jab him and work him
and it's not the time that he wants to
go for the knockout
okay so castano is stalking him again
and he tried to throw a left hook from
too far out
all right so they're back in the uh and
against the ropes with castano stalking
him
and he throws a left hook to
jamel jamel throws a left hook and a
right hand back
there's a lot of movement from jamel a
lot of jabbing but castano is stalking
him well he has him up against the ropes
but jamel catches him with that same
left hook
through the guard
all right so now jamel doesn't want to
hold at all and
castano is forcing the action while
jamel is going up top with his jab and
down low and he catches jamel with a
right hand and he catches jamel with
another right hand
uh and jamel catches castano with an
uppercut
jamel has a nice chin
but he just got quote order one two
and castano is on jamel with a one two
and jamela's missing some of his shots
and he's coming up the middle castano's
keeping it tight and staying on him now
he's cutting off the ring he's not
following him around the ring he's
cutting off the ring and he's going it
with his jab and he's jabbing his weight
and
castano is stalking oh straight right
hand from jamelle
that rocks castano's head back
and he drops another right hand on the
left hook castano has one hell of a chin
oh he got caught with a one two
castano is there to be hit and jamel is
there to hit him
staniel backs off a little bit
and he comes in he catches jamel with a
left oh and jamel catches castano with a
right hand all right
if i want to be somebody at the end of
this they keep doing this at the end of
this round this is out of control if you
want to be somebody at the end of that
round i gotta be jamelle
yo that's crazy it's four to two
to be honest with you but he catches him
with some hay makers
they are giving and taking
yo
this is a beautiful fight i told you
this this this could be fight of the
year as far as what they're willing to
do what they're willing to lay on the
line right so both of these dudes is
laying it on the line you got you got
jamel throwing straight long right hands
like that that's outrageous and then you
got castano still stalking him eating
the shots standing in front of him and
getting the left right to the body into
the head this is kind of crazy
all right here we go these dudes just
fighting and whoever's gonna get this
win is going to earn this win they're
gonna fill this win tomorrow
all right so they're back in the center
to the ring this is round seven
here we go
castano's not that eager to run across
that ring like that
but castano is back to stalking so he's
throwing a jab and and jamel throws a
jab to his body
all right and castano's back he's
guarding his uh right eye
his right eye is the one that has a
little bit of the puffiness to it
all right jamel throws a one-two to
castano's body
castano is still stalking jamel and
pushing them back against the ropes
nice jab from uh castano
all right and castano is still stalking
he throws a jab at jamelle jamal goes
right back to castano's body
and
they're back to the jabbing game i guess
they both got hurt the last round they
need to take a break off i guess round
seven is the break unless somebody goes
in and goes for the kill
castano is still walking him down
and he's jabbing his way in
jamel throws a 1-2 to push him back but
castano doesn't give him anything to hit
jamal goes right back to the top and
right back to the bottom
all right castanya throws oh
he throws a 1-2 jamel hits him with a
straight right hand and does not go in
to finish him i don't understand why
doesn't jemele go in to finish castano
he gets kiss daniel hurt and he steps
off the gas
that's the difference between a lot of
other fighters
right jamelle
wants a clean knockout
and he's looking for a clean knockout
and he's not
pounding
paul's uh castano
to receive the knockout it doesn't make
any sense
i guess he's respecting castano's
ability to hurt him as well
all right so they're back in the center
of the ring again
uh one two by jamelle
jamel is throwing that jab because
daniel's not really doing too much he's
jabbing and trying to come in with a
right hand
and jamelle is you know sidestepping
giving him lateral movement back to back
and back to jabbing so he's in the
corner castano tries to unload but
jamel steps out of the corner
now he's following jemele he's not
cutting the ring off jamel throws a jab
up top
and he continues
back up
top and
castano
oh one two three from jemele
and castano tries to come in
a couple of seconds when the round is
almost over to try to steal around
but it doesn't work
and
i give jemele that round as well
right now
he said i see zab judah in the
background yeah
yeah so much for walking him down
yeah
to see errol spencer's telling him what
the hell are you doing man
you got him knock him out
um yeah i i give it uh
yeah i give him five rounds too
honestly
i don't know for the life of me why the
hell jamel has him in trouble and
doesn't finish off
the the prey look at that straight right
hand left hook
okay and he stays on him but okay that
wasn't the punch that got
uh castano in trouble in my opinion
estonia misses the shot and jamel throws
a blind left hook that was the shot that
got castano in trouble
the blind left hook is what got him in
trouble
all right so they're back in the center
of the rings round eight
and you have castano stalking him again
and jamel is throwing the jab and
stepping back
again continue the same thing
right hand left hook
right hand i mean jab
jab
and they're just posing for each other
right now
jab jab right hand from jemele
that was a weird awkward movement
castano is still in front of him he
throws a one-two now cassandra's got
some pop in him
and jamella's back to his jab
while castano
is in front of jamel he catches jamel
with a straight right hand
what i told you
castano
throws a right hand but jemele catches
him with a uppercut
and castano is there in front of him
walking him down
jamel throws a jab castano comes with a
left hook
and they're right there again
so jamel is back to jabbing
castano is back to stalking
and costando comes back again jamel
misses with a straight right hand
and then castano comes in
still
pressuring him
jamel is back to jabbing
it's a little bit of a tame around
and it's really uh all right so the
activity is really conducive upon
castano willingness to engage right so
he's pushing jamal back and jamal's
throwing left right hand from jamal over
the top
jab
right hand from castano over the top
left hook from castano
castano tried the right hand
jamel wasn't there
one two and he's sticking the jab
right hand from castagna i mean from
jamelle wasn't there
sanji tries a left hook and now he has
jamal up begins to rope draw jamal lands
the left hook against castano head and
circles out
all right jab straight to the body from
jamal cassano lands a right hand over
this the lazy jab
they're both doing the same thing
castano is throwing the
right hand landing it
and
jamel is landing the left
i would give that round to castano i
think castano was looking more to win so
um
what what i would have that that would
be five
to four
i believe five to four
and got cassandra only winning two
rounds so far jamel's not trying to
finish because he doesn't
want to get tired
yeah
that's that's that's probably the case
that he probably doesn't want to get
tired he wants to hold something in the
tank but you gotta dare to be great
but i think that's more or less the
respect that he has for him as a
champion to be honest with you
because he's catching him with some hell
of alicia shots and castano is still
there
regardless to what
these dudes is is is giving a hundred
and ten percent inside this ring
and there's some respect yeah jamal
looks a little winded so does castano
excuse me
ninth round
so you got uh
jamel to throwing jabs because daniel
comes out with a left hook and a right
hand and misses jamel catches him with a
one two
catches them with a left hook right hand
castanya uh tries to get jamal against
the ropes but jamel throws that fury and
spins off the ropes back to the stepping
jab jamel as as castano is walking
in
one two by kiss by uh jamelle that
catches castano clean in his face
and
castano is still there in the pocket
this is what i'm talking about he
catches them clean but he doesn't finish
up because he like you said maybe he
doesn't want to get tired but maybe he
understands that this dude could be
playing possum
one two
by jamelle
jamel throws a one
and one straight to the body
all right so they're back in the center
of the ring castano is stalking giving a
lot of head moving but not throwing any
punches jamal throws a
left jab and a left uppercut under the
rib cage and spins out
and castano has him against the ropes
trying to work he tries to throw the
right hand
but
jamal spins out of the corner
cassandra tries to throw a left hook
jamal ducks under the left hook and
shoots a jab
one two from jamal and he steps out
and he goes back up to the uppercut
and he grabs a grappling in the center
of the ring the referee breaks them up
and castano catches uh jamal with a jab
jamal goes right back to his jab
and here we go
we have uh
castano goes straight to his body
right hand left hook
jamal gets off the ropes by throwing uh
four shots to get off the ropes and
estania tries to land that right hand i
think that right hand was the one he was
setting up the whole fight to be honest
with you and he missed it
all right so jamal is in the corner
cassano is coming in
trying to land some shots jamal spins
out
like oh and he catches castano with
another left hook
and another right hand and they're
they're trading shots against the ropes
and jamal spins out and throws a couple
of good shots
nice shot to the body jamal comes right
back to castano's body
but cassano is stalking very very well
this is definitely incredible stuff here
and castano catches jamal with a good
shot and jamal catches castano pushes
down
give that round to jamal
jamal did more work castano did more
following
nice shots that castano's throwing but
again castano is just stalking and when
you're just stalking without head
movement without throwing any jabs you
get caught with a straight right hand
like he just did
i got to check
yeah it's a great fight it's a great
fight um
so far
i got to check who i got i got to check
the the mme what's going on see they're
they're both giving and taking they're
both landing great shots you got one
throwing the jab that's busy as hell
with the jab in the right hand and you
got another one that is busy as hell
with the stalking that takes a lot of
ring expertise so it's really who you're
going to give it to
but they're back up and we're in the
championship rounds now we're in the
10th 10th round
so let's go they meet in the center of
the ring and they're throwing in the
center of the ring
excuse me
castano came in swinging uh hooks in the
center of the ring
and jamel is throwing straight punches
this has been the tail of the fight
jamel straight punches and castano short
punches jamel throws a short left hook
up under
and
right there nice left right to the body
castano is actually
fighting his tail off
and he's stalking jamel
stalking with a nice right hand
left up
double left hook from castano but
jamel's not there
jamel throws a left to the body and
throws a right to the head
all right oh
castano catches jamel with the right and
jamello catches him with one two
right in the center of the ring jamel is
going back to the jab and digging to the
body
right hand from castano left hook from
jamel
left hook from castano right hand from
jamelle
they're trading shots in the center of
the ring
nobody wants to give up their belts
who's going to take it
so we got jamel again
and castano stalking them and jamelle is
coming up the middle with his shots
and castano is again stalking
jamel is throwing his jab but he's
they're covered up right now castaneda
throws a one two catches jamelle
and he's stalking him high guard and he
pushes jamel back
jab
from jamel
castano catches jemele with a right hand
up against the ropes another right hand
and jamelle catches
cassandra with a left hook
so again jamelle is being stalked by
castaneda costano lands oh
jamel court castano with a left hook
inside and dropped him
he is out on his feet
it's over if jamel is let loose it's 40
seconds to go jamelle is going to try to
finish him castano's done the fight is
over he caught cassano to the body with
a left hook to the head the fight is
over folks this man is not gonna get up
it is over the fight is over that is a
knockout he saved it for the last that
left hook inside was
incredible we have a unified unanimous
undisputed
junior i mean super middle uh walter
weight champion of the world super
walter weight champion of the world
jamel charlo knocks out castano
yo the left hook to the body was sick
but that left hook up top was something
to be feared
he caught him his body said excuse me
and left
his body left
yo
that left hook
inside was so tight
he wasn't prepared for it he got hit by
it and his body crumbled like a deck of
cards that's right derek james is got to
be the the the the train of the year
he has to be coach of the year he has to
be
are you are you serious
you got
one fighter that has come back
and got all three belts and is in his
pushing but then you got another fighter
that is undisputed
undisputed
super
or waterweight champion 154
that's incredible and to do it like that
that was a hell of a fight that's right
you called the ko you definitely did i
don't know if you called it in the 10th
round or the 9th round but you called
that ko i thought he was gonna cruise to
a 12 round decision i thought he was
going to get 12 rounds out of this but
i'm gonna tell you right now
that left hook was from the gods
he caught him with that left hook it was
something serious to be seen i'm just
sitting here waiting to see it again
right before we get up out of here this
the drinks is on iop is popping tomorrow
you already know we got david jaffee in
the building so that's gonna definitely
be a bomb burner and then you got me on
fonzarelli show that's uh oh man that's
that's going to be
one hell
of a sunday
i gotta give a shout out to everybody
that pulled up everybody that pulled up
with combat talk you guys make make me
make sure that i do this
this is what it is man
this is what it is remember next week is
no fight next week xp that's what's up
ten dollar super chat
fighting is spiritual yes yes yes it is
sir yes it is uh yes it is uh 100
is spiritual
emotional
connecting look yo look at this
so right there castanya did that and
that left hook inside
was
nuts
because daniel body just broke down
the left hook inside was absolutely
bananas and he broke down but then the
left hook to his body
in the next in the next sequence because
they they keep showing the uppercut left
hook
uppercut left hook there it is
it's smashed in and i told you it was
the left hook that he was kept landing
with castano and castano his his ability
to win was the right hand
i gotta see
the next knockdown because yo let's give
let's give castano a round of applause
because your man got up
your man got up yo
your man got up
he got up off of that
not too many dudes would have got it
speaking of that jerome and it's just
for clayton clayton didn't get up off a
shot that didn't even look nothing like
that right so let's let's let's be
respectful of this champion that was
there to fight let's be respectful for
that champion 100
jamel charlo all right so this is this
is
right here
right hand
left hook
oh they're left to the body cause daniel
just got
pushed right over to the side that was
absolutely nuts that was a fantastic
fight
i got to tell you guys man thank you
again
for coming through
hanging out with the king
uh this combat talk with the king
this is fantastic stuff that we got
going on here man
truly respect you guys
let's give you this
uh
as we get out of here
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome
presents the featured event of the
evening
as tonight
[Music]
presented boxing
fights
[Music]
[Music]
welcome
ain't no competition in the ring
decipher cause i'm spitting finally i'm
swinging fire talking pickled peppers
make em pay the piper cause i might go
look like a rude discussion and deflate
your chest like a fool production you'll
be talking like you want a new
concussion center due to custom attitude
adjustments
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sandwich i will serve heaven's
tipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you michael
jackson even got his one and only homie
captain you were phony homie now you owe
me action have him sinking tony tony
tony braxton and they all want to talk
for attention but the fame only lasts
for an instant mama got hands so i'm
ready for the picture i'ma leave him red
you can dance
[Music]